temperature has completely cooled down as I try to get acquainted with the humans who are flirting with each other.
[Music] What are you trying to do, little
girl? Are you just trying
to be cute? You're a nuisance, I do
n't like it. This doesn't mean you'll become a problem for our dinosaur tribe.
[Music] I don't
like it.
Otherwise,
your path to justice will be cut off. Your
fate is in my hands.
Alright, don't go against this person. As for me, it's
fine. I'm used to things like this.
Old people are wise.
To lose sight of the main text due to a temporary cheap sense of justice. That's
not a proper vessel anyway. Now you have a choice. Make a
wise decision and connect the future, or
destroy yourself for one of them.
Sally.  I believe in you, in your
decision,
King, I'm
sorry, but it seems like I ca
n't be your queen. Are you
going to protect one? That's right.
If you want to be by my side to support what you said, then here it is.  That's why,
even if I could become a queen someday like this, I wouldn't be able to be next to the king.I want to
be the kind of person who can stand proudly next to the king.Otherwise, no
one else will.
Because I can't see the same future as the king who aspires to a world where no one can be hurt.